Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速和大家分享一件目前正在进行、非常令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间去换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）主办的“向持续收入冲刺挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是从事完全不同领域的工作，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. People talk about the sweet spot of work-life balance, but what if that is hard to
这些原则对你同样适用。挑战赛还设有由丽莎亲自送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一辅导一小时的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个快速私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。人们常谈论工作与生活的完美平衡，但如果这个目标很难
achieve? What if both of those pressures feel like they are meaning that you are heading towards burnout? Let's take a deep dive looking at all of the different types of factors that can contribute to you or someone you care about feeling burned out. I hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. For the last five episodes, I have been bringing you a special, special, special series on burnout, or more specifically, what burnout is and how to avoid it, both for yourself, for those that you might be working with, and or those you care about. It has been my pleasure to work alongside Dr. Claire Plumley, who is also a qualified clinical psychologist and the author
达成呢？如果这两种压力都意味着你正在走向精疲力竭（职业倦怠）呢？让我们深入探讨一下，导致你或你在乎的人感到精疲力竭的各种不同因素。希望你能从中受益。嗨，欢迎收听“有抱负的心理学家播客”（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。在过去的五集里，我为大家带来了一个关于职业倦怠的特别系列——更具体地说，什么是职业倦怠以及如何避免它，无论对你自己、与你共事的人，还是你关心的人。非常荣幸能与克莱尔·普拉姆利博士（Dr. Claire Plumley）合作，她也是一位合格的临床心理学家，并且是
of a brilliant new book on burnout. We have evidenced during this series that teamwork makes the dream work and it's always okay to have people support you. You don't need to worry about me. I'm not going anywhere. It's just that over the summer, it can be a little bit of a juggle with the children. I wanted to make sure I was still providing you super brilliant, useful content whenever you are ready to listen or watch it. Claire is really spoiling us with our final installment of the Burnout Byte. Absolutely don't need to have listened to the previous five episodes, but I would recommend that you do because they are exceptional. Let's dive in and hear our final burnout bite with Dr. Claire. Hello and welcome to the final of Burnout Bites.
一本关于职业倦怠的精彩新书的作者。我们在本系列中证明了“团队合作成就梦想”，而且寻求他人的支持永远是可以的。你们不用为我担心。我哪儿也不去。只是在夏天，照顾孩子确实需要手忙脚乱一阵子。我想确保无论你何时准备收听或观看，我都能为你提供超级精彩、有用的内容。克莱尔在我们的最后一期“职业倦怠小贴士”（Burnout Byte）中真的给我们带来了满满的干货。你绝对不需要听过前五集，但我建议你听一下，因为它们非常出色。让我们一听为快，聆听克莱尔带来的最后一期职业倦怠小贴士。你好，欢迎来到最后一期“职业倦怠小贴士”。
This has been a series of six short episodes that I've brought to you all about this topic of burnout in the hope that we can understand it and take collective action to looking after ourselves and protecting those around us as well. I'm Dr. Claire Plumley. I am a clinical psychologist. I work with people who have experienced trauma and are feeling anxious or burnt out. And I have a clinical practice both online and in Taunton Somerset. And I have recently written a book. The book's called Burnout, How to Manage Your Nervous System Before It Manages You. The link is in the show notes and a lot of the nuggets I've brought to you over this short series has been from that. So today I wanted to bring you this idea of the difference between external and internal pressures because on the surface you'd think it would be
这是一个包含六集短节目的系列，我围绕职业倦怠这个话题与大家探讨，希望我们能理解它，并采取集体行动来照顾好自己、保护我们周围的人。我是克莱尔·普拉姆利博士。我是一名临床心理学家。我主要为经历过创伤、感到焦虑或精疲力竭的人提供帮助。我在萨默塞特郡汤顿（Taunton Somerset）在线和线下都设有诊所。我最近写了一本书，书名叫《职业倦怠：在你的神经系统掌控你之前，如何掌控你的神经系统》（Burnout: How to Manage Your Nervous System Before It Manages You）。链接就在节目文稿中，我在这个短系列中分享的许多干货都来源于这本书。所以今天，我想和大家探讨外部压力和内部压力之间的区别，因为表面上看，我们会认为这很简单：
simple if we're feeling stressed that we would slow down and pace ourselves and pause and rest so that we don't then tip into this more closed out, overwhelmed, burnt out place. But there are two reasons that we don't. There are external pressures that come from the people and situations around us. And there are internal pressures that come from within us. So I'm going to break that down today so you have a little bit more of an understanding of it. External pressures include the types of demands in our lives that are really hard to escape from. So it's the boring adulting type of things that we have to just get on and do, unfortunately. So bills to pay, high caseload, dependents like children or elderly parents.
如果我们感到压力山大，我们就应该慢下来、调整节奏、暂停并休息，这样我们就不会陷入那种更加封闭、不知所措、精疲力竭的状态。但我们没有这样做的原因有两个。一是来自我们周围的人和情况的外部压力；二是来自我们内心的内部压力。所以我今天将对其进行剖析，让你对它有更多一点的了解。外部压力包括生活中那些极难摆脱的需求。不幸的是，这就是那些不得不硬着头皮去完成的无聊的成年人日常琐事。比如要支付的账单、繁重的工作量、需要抚养的儿童或年迈的父母。
It might be quarterly targets or questions and wants from the people in our lives who we really care about. The thing with these external pressures is that sometimes they're super obvious, but sometimes there's a little chipping away effect that can go on. They can just start to mount up. And when I worked in my NHS job job this happened in a really gradual way and often on their own each little demand felt almost inconsequential and like i would be creating a bit of a fuss if i said anything about this so for example when i first started to work in the nhs as a full-time equivalent you were expected to see about 15 clients a week. When I left that position, which was almost seven years later, a full time equivalent was expected to see 25 clients in a week. Not only that, but
这可能是季度目标，或者生活中我们真正在乎的人提出的问题和期望。这些外部压力的特点是，有时它们非常明显，但有时它们会产生一种一点点侵蚀的效果。它们开始不断累积。当我在国民保健署（NHS）工作时，这种情况是非常渐进地发生的，通常每一个小需求单看都微不足道，而且如果我说什么的话，会显得我在小题大做，所以，例如，当我刚开始在 NHS 担任全职工作时，预计每周大约要看 15 位客户。当我离开那个岗位时——差不多是七年之后——全职人员每周需要看 25 位客户。不仅如此，而且
we were expected to do measures at each session and provide more reports. It was just a lot. And it hadn't become quite clear to me until I sat down and really thought about it how much more I was being asked to do. So here's a list of the common external pressures so you can just check in and see how many of these you've got going on. Holding in mind that this won't just be at work this will be in your personal life and friendship life and any maybe voluntary commitments that you have as well so take it as a broad brushstroke. Time pressures. So this might be deadlines, completing projects, or, you know, on a day-to-day basis where you've got to get somewhere at a certain time, get the kids to a club at a certain time. Any conflicts or disagreement where you're kind of feeling this constant pressure of being
我们被要求在每次会诊时都进行量化评估，并提供更多报告。工作量实在是太大了。直到我坐下来认真思考，我才真正意识到我被要求做的事情多了多少。所以这里列出了一些常见的外部压力，你可以自我对照一下，看看你有多少正在经历。请记住，这不仅会发生在工作中，还会发生在你的个人生活、友谊生活以及你可能拥有的任何志愿服务承诺中，所以请把它作为一个宏观的概括。时间压力。这可能是截止日期、完成项目，或者在日常生活中，你必须在某个特定时间赶到某地，在某个特定时间送孩子去俱乐部。任何冲突或分歧，都会让你有一种持续的压力感，即
up against someone else or friction. Any high emotional labour in your job. So tending to others and negative emotions and not having emotional support for your own this is a really strong external pressure that can be a bit more invisible workload just having too much to do and obviously that ties in with the time pressure often not enough time to do it this is an interesting one role ambiguity so when you're not quite sure what you should be doing or you don't want to step on the toes others, there can be a lot of energy that gets used up there with decision making and trying to work out the best course of action. When we don't have a control over our situation, or the resources available to us, or the demands being made, excessive criticism from others. This is
与他人对抗或产生摩擦。工作中需要付出大量的情感劳动。也就是照顾他人的负面情绪，却没有为自己的情绪提供支持，这是一种非常强烈、可能更隐蔽的外部压力。工作量，即有做不完的事情，显然这通常与时间压力交织在一起，常常没有足够的时间去完成。这是一个很有趣的现象：角色模糊。也就是当你不太确定自己应该做什么，或者不想踩到别人的脚时，在决策和试图找出最佳行动方案的过程中，会消耗大量的精力。当我们无法控制自己的情况、可用的资源或提出的要求时，来自他人的过度批评。这是一个
a really tricky one, again, that can feel like it's beyond our control. And it links into the next one, which is lack of positive feedback or appreciation. So if we're doing all of this work, but without this extra of people noticing and seeing what we're doing, when there's any insecurity in our life, so uncertainty can really drain us. So job insecurity, not knowing how long we're going to be in a post or having to continually reapply for work this is really hard for us complex tasks or a lot of complex tasks so we can't just kind of automate out certain things and kind of just know this is how I'm always doing things if we're having to always wrap our head around more complexity and new instructions this is really again an external pressure pressure coming in at us from the type of work that we're doing. Of course, last but not least is financial worries. So a lot of external pressures are visible and obvious, but not always.
非常棘手的问题，同样会让人觉得超出了我们的控制。这与下一个问题有关，即缺乏积极的反馈或赞赏。所以，如果我们做了所有这些工作，却没有得到别人注意到并看到我们在做什么的额外反馈，当生活中有任何不安全感时，不确定性真的会消耗我们的精力。比如工作不稳定，不知道能在某个岗位上呆多久，或者不得不不断重新申请工作，这让我们感到非常艰难。复杂的任务或大量复杂的任务，这意味着我们不能只是把某些事情自动化，然后就知道这就是我一直以来的做事方式。如果我们不得不总是去理解更多的复杂性和新的指令，这也是一种外部压力，来自于我们所做的工作的性质。当然，最后但同样重要的是财务担忧。所以，许多外部压力是可见且显而易见的，但并非总是如此。
There can be some cultural ideals or ways that we expect men, women, carers to behave in a certain way that can also add to the type of external pressure certain people are under. I go into this in chapter seven in my book, but I just want to introduce that idea right now that not all external pressures are easy to put your finger on. Some of them might just be almost an expectation that you kind of don't recognize that this could be something that you question or hold at arm's length to look at and decide actually is this something that I do need to always be responding to. So some of these are really practical external pressures that we might be able to do something about. Sometimes we do have more control than we realize and we stop and spend some time working on what those options are to reduce external pressures then that's a really valuable piece of work. But there are some external
还可能存在一些文化理想，或者我们期望男性、女性、照顾者以某种特定方式行事的行为模式，这也可能增加某些人所承受的外部压力。我在书中的第七章中详细探讨了这一点，但我现在只想引入这个概念：并非所有的外部压力都容易一眼看出。其中一些可能几乎是一种期望，而你甚至没有意识到这可能是你可以质疑或保持距离去审视的事情，并决定这是否真的是我需要一直回应的事情。因此，其中一些是非常实际的外部压力，我们或许可以对此做点什么。有时我们拥有比自己意识到的更多的控制权，如果我们停下来花时间研究减少外部压力的那些选项，那么这是一项非常有价值的工作。但也有一些外部
pressures that are less visible to us. And they can often come from ideas that are woven into our culture. So for example, about our roles, what's expected from us, for example, that's different for men and women, it might also be different depending on your role in the family, your role at work. So for example, women as carers, men as breadwinners, that's a very common one that most people can see as really unhelpful. And I go into this in one of the chapters in my book, trying to help people understand the narratives that might underlie all of this. But just know for now that there are very obvious visible external pressures that we might be able to do something about. And there are others that are harder for us to fight on our own and actually this takes collective understanding and action
压力对我们来说不太明显。它们通常源于融入我们文化的观念。例如，关于我们的角色、对我们的期望，例如男性和女性是不同的，它也可能因你在家庭中的角色、在工作中的角色而异。例如，女性作为照顾者，男性作为顶梁柱，这是一个绝大多数人都能看出毫无帮助的非常普遍的现象。我在书中的其中一章中探讨了这一点，试图帮助人们理解可能隐藏这一切背后的叙事。但现在只要知道，有非常明显可见的外部压力，我们或许可以做点什么；还有其他一些外部压力，靠我们自己很难去对抗，实际上这需要集体的理解和行动来挑战。
to challenge. The second type of pressure is internal and this comes from pressures inside us such as our emotions and our thoughts. This can motivate us on through stress even when we're feeling really quite tired and we don't have much more to give. It can be informed partly by our biological and psychological makeup, such as our personality traits, core beliefs, any sensitivity to stimuli and temperament. And it tends to show up as things like emotions, guilt, anxiety, shame, thoughts, such as, well, I'm responsible for keeping everything together, or I've not done enough yet to deserve a break. And also unpleasant sensations in the body, which are linked to stress, such as that rush of adrenaline. Everything then feels urgent. Muscles are tense. Your heart's racing. You feel fidgety.
第二种压力是内部压力，它来自我们内部的压力，例如我们的情绪和想法。即使在我们感到非常疲惫、感觉快要油尽灯枯时，它也能激励我们顶着压力继续前进。它部分由我们的生物和心理构成所塑造，例如我们的性格特征、核心信念、对刺激的敏感度以及气质。它通常表现为诸如情绪、内疚、焦虑、羞耻等形式，以及诸如“嗯，我有责任把一切维系在一起”或“我做得还不够，不配休息”之类的想法。还有与压力相关的、身体上令人不快的感觉，例如肾上腺素飙升。这时一切都变得十万火急。肌肉紧绷。心跳加速。你感到坐立不安。
The idea of trying to pause or slow down just seems to go against what your nervous system is telling you. In my book, I talk about three patterns of internal pressures that I see a lot in burnout in my work. So the first is people pleasing. So obviously being nice and kind to people isn't bad in and of itself. But people pleasing is when it tips into feeling like you're worthless unless others are happy. Your needs are bottom of the pile. And so all of the thoughts and emotions and internal sensations are linked to that. If you have any sense that others aren't feeling okay about things that you're doing, you will feel
试图停下来或放慢脚步的想法，似乎与你的神经系统正在告诉你的信号背道而驰。在我的书中，我谈到了我在工作中经常在职业倦怠中看到的三种内部压力模式。第一种是讨好型人格。显然，对人友好和善良本身并不是坏事。但讨好型人格是指，如果别人不高兴，你就会觉得自己一文不值，这种心态走向极端。你的需求被排在最末位。因此，所有的想法、情绪和内部感受都与此挂钩。如果你有任何感觉，觉得别人对你所做的事情感觉不太好，你就会感到一种去纠正并讨好他们的冲动。
an urge to fix that and people please. The second is perfectionism. Again, the wish to do things well isn't in and of itself a bad thing. It's when this tips into an exhausting pursuit of perfection at the expense of your well-being so not resting and not pausing and never delegating for fear of others getting things wrong and this is usually fueled from a negative place fearing the worst if you don't get things just so the others will reject you or you'll be criticized or put down and so again the internal pressures will tend to revolve around specific worry thoughts about exactly that what will happen if things aren't perfect and you get all of the internal sensations linked to moving on always keeping your foot on the gas. Third that I go into my book is this avoidance of emotions by
第二种是完美主义。同样，把事情做好的愿望本身并不是坏事。这是当它演变成一种以牺牲幸福感为代价、对完美的精疲力竭的追求时——由于害怕别人把事情搞砸，所以不休息、不暂停、从不授权。这通常是由消极的动机驱动的：如果事情做得不够完美，就会担心最坏的结果，担心别人会拒绝你，或者你会受到批评或贬低。因此，内部压力往往围绕着具体担忧的想法展开：如果事情不完美会发生什么，你总是会得到与不断前行、永远踩着油门相关的内在感受。我在书里探讨的第三种是利用
using busyness so if you fear your own body you fear your own emotions which can be you know really common negative emotions are really unpleasant as we know pretty much a lot of our work in psychology is about helping people develop a more compassionate relationship with their emotions but it's really understandable that we would try and avoid negativity and when we haven't had experience growing up of this building up our confidence in our ability to be attuned and respond to our body this can cause people to overuse work as a strategy and so you might have these internal thoughts of I can't cope with negative anxiety or other emotions what if this tips me into a really difficult place I can never come back from so I hope this is helpful
忙碌来逃避情绪。如果你恐惧自己的身体，恐惧自己的情绪——如我们所知，众所周知，负面情绪确实非常令人不快，我们在心理学中的大部分工作实际上都是为了帮助人们与自己的情绪建立更具同情心的关系。但我们试图逃避消极情绪是完全可以理解的，当我们成长过程中没有这方面的经验来建立对自我调节和回应身体能力的信心时，这会导致人们过度将工作作为一种应对策略。因此，你可能会产生这样的内心想法：“我无法应对负面的焦虑或其他情绪，如果这把我推向一个我永远无法回头的艰难境地怎么办？”所以我希望这有助于
for separating it out beginning to think about what what are the areas where I have control yes there are some areas of external pressures that I might benefit from stopping and trying to problem solve maybe getting some support with and that might involve like practical and investment as well to try and get external pressures down and then there are internal pressures that is more role of self-improvement and self-healing and you know the role of a psychologist can help with this again absolutely these areas are things that we can do something about but you've got to be aware of what your internal patterns are and know how to slow it all down before responding before you do that so possibly reading my book if you've got time or listening to it on audible or
将它们剥离开来，开始思考：哪些是我可以掌控的领域？是的，外部压力中确实有一些领域，如果我停下来并尝试解决问题，可能会受益匪浅，也许还能得到一些支持，这可能也需要实际的投入和投资，以试图降低外部压力。然后是内部压力，这更多是自我提升和自我治愈的角色。你知道，心理学家的角色可以对此有所帮助。再次强调，这些领域绝对是我们可以采取行动的，但在你这样做之前，你必须意识到自己的内部模式是什么，并知道在做出反应之前如何放慢一切。所以，如果你有时间，可以读读我的书，或者在 Audible 上听，
doing any of your own continued work that you might already have up your sleeve like your mindfulness practices or any other therapeutic approaches compassion focus therapy and acts these are all really really helpful for trying to move through these patterns in a way or change your relationship with them i really hope you found this series of six episodes on burnout helpful i'd love to connect with you in my social media if you would like to find me i'm on Instagram I'm on TikTok I'm on Facebook and LinkedIn you can also like I say check out my book and if you're on my mailing list I love to get replies so do check out my mailing list you can access that via the website all of the links to these are in the show notes
或者做任何你已经掌握的持续练习，比如正念练习或其他治疗方法——正念减压疗法、慈悲焦点疗法和接纳承诺疗法（ACT），这些对于以某种方式度过这些模式或改变你与它们的关系都非常非常有帮助。我真的希望你觉得这六集关于职业倦怠的播客很有帮助。如果你想找到我，我很乐意在社交媒体上与你互动。我在 Instagram、TikTok、Facebook 和 LinkedIn 上。就像我说的，你也可以看看我的书。如果你在我的邮件订阅名单上，我喜欢收到回复，所以一定要查看我的邮件订阅名单，你可以通过网站访问它。所有这些链接都在节目文稿中，
and I will now hand you back to Marianne who who is going to bring you her next episode. As usual, the slightly longer episodes that you are more accustomed to. Thank you very much for having me. And Marianne, thank you for allowing me this platform. Oh, thank you so much, Claire. And it's been lovely having you head up the podcast for this last six weeks, and you've done a beautiful job. So thank you for sharing so generously with my audience. And please, to you, my audience, if you have found it useful, please do join Claire's mailing list. And of course, grab your copy of Burnout, How to Manage Your Nervous System Before It Manages You. If you've already bought it,
现在我将把时间交还给玛丽安，她将为你带来她的下一集。像往常一样，这是你更习惯的稍长的节目。非常感谢邀请我来。玛丽安，谢谢你给我这个平台。噢，太谢谢你了，克莱尔。在过去的六周里，由你来主持播客真是太棒了，你做得非常出色。谢谢你如此慷慨地与我的听众分享。请你们——我的听众们，如果你们觉得有用，请务必加入克莱尔的邮件订阅名单。当然，还要买一本《职业倦怠：在你的神经系统掌控你之前，如何掌控你的神经系统》。如果你已经买了，
please do rate and review on Amazon. I hope you found this to be a really, really wonderful use of the last six weeks of your time. I would love any feedback that you might have about it. Please do come and connect with me and discuss in my free Facebook group, The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. Come and connect with me on my happy hangouts on socials. I'm always on LinkedIn, so that's a great place to follow me, but I'm everywhere. Dr. Marianne Trent. Come and follow me on Insta, TikTok, all of those great places. And let me know what content you would like. Don't forget that we have Marianne's motivation and mindset sessions, which happen weekly for free, exclusively in the free Facebook group.
请务必在亚马逊上给予评分和评价。我希望你觉得这是过去六周时间里一次非常非常美妙的体验。我很乐意听到你对它的任何反馈。请来和我联系，并在我的免费 Facebook 群组“由玛丽安·特伦特博士陪伴的有抱负的心理学家社区”（The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent）中进行讨论。快来我的社交媒体快乐聚集地与我互动吧。我一直在 LinkedIn 上，所以那是关注我的绝佳地方，但我无处不在：玛丽安·特伦特博士。快来 Insta、TikTok 所有这些好地方关注我吧。并告诉我你想看什么内容。别忘了我们有玛丽安的动力和心态课程，每周免费举办一次，仅在免费 Facebook 群组中独家提供。
And if you love what we do here on the podcast, I think you will adore what we do in the Aspiring Psychologist membership. If you would like to access that, you can do for just £30 a month with no minimum term. And do remember the free psychology success guide, which you can get by going to my website, www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk, and then head to the top for free resources. If you have already read the Clinical Psychologist Collective and the Aspiring Psychologist Collective, please do drop me some ratings and reviews on amazon and on goodreads i am so privileged that you are part of my world and i will look forward to bringing you the next episode which will be along from 10 a.m on saturday on youtube and from 6 a.m on monday wherever you get your podcasts thank you again be kind to yourself and to those around you and I'll look forward
如果你喜欢我们在播客中所做的事情，我想你会非常喜欢我们在“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”（Aspiring Psychologist Membership）中所做的事情。如果你想加入，每月只需 30 英镑，没有最低期限限制。请记住免费的心理学成功指南，你可以通过访问我的网站 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk，然后点击顶部的“免费资源”（free resources）来获取。如果你已经阅读了《临床心理学家合集》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）和《有抱负的心理学家合集》（Aspiring Psychologist Collective），请务必在亚马逊和 Goodreads 上给我一些评分和评价。我很荣幸你能成为我世界的一部分，我期待着为你带来下一集，该节目将于周六上午 10 点起在 YouTube 上线，周一上午 6 点起在各大播客平台上线。再次感谢，善待自己，善待周围的人，我期待着
to seeing you very soon. Take care. to be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with Dr Marianne Turris My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself.
很快与你相见。保重。在成为合格心理学家的路上，这里是“有抱负的心理学家播客”，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我叫亚娜，我是一名见习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现里面所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历都非常有趣。成为临床心理学家竟然有这么多不同的途径，这让我感到惊讶，而且成为其中一员并没有唯一的完美方式，这给了我信心，让我确信我没有做错，并减轻了我给自己的压力。
So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会把书放下。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。